All right guys, so here's another example of the Asian session liquidity trading strategy
So as you can see price was making
lower low lower high lower low lower high
lower low lower high and then we strapped the
If I zoom in
You can see we stripped the Asian session low during the the lunch break, right?
and then what we had here was a
market structure shift
Okay, and it just broke up with um a lot of momentum, okay
So what do we have here now is we got
Some of the imbalance around here, all right, and we got this autoblock around here
Now if you mark out the very extreme level, you will still have gotten an entry because as i said before you must keep your
entry point a bit
Above the actual entry point to deal with the spreads, okay, or a worst case scenario you can have
Entered at around this autobock, okay, and you would have your stop loss below this level
And then you would target the Asian session high. This would have been a six
Restore what but if you had your entry around here and you stop here. This would have been a
Restore what trade so guys this is like a FTM or challenge passed with one single trade, okay?
So what i'm teaching right now, it's incredible
You will not find it anywhere on the youtube or any other courses, maybe a few people know about this
but this is the
Deal guys trust me all right